giving Willie Wonka New Life wasn't the
only part of the film that was a
challenge for Timothy shalam the fact
that Wonka is a musical also provided
its fair share of difficulties there was
more training that went into this than
maybe anything i' ever worked on because
there's an element of song and dance
that you have to spend
months uh prepping obviously for the
songs you got to record them and just
how difficult dance numbers are took the
actor by surprise for the dance numbers
I've talked about before but I was
really humbled by it's not simply about
raw expression you really got to stay in
the center of frame on some shots some
shots you might be killing it but
another dancer might have messed up you
know all sorts of variables that you
wouldn't really consider in a Ab talking
scene you know